I am losing my mind over this new flower arrangement.
Oh, look at this. So cool.
I know, isn't this amazing?
I just want to thank our friends at Fetter Bane,
the Philly flower shop that made this for us!
Wow! Really phenomenal work.
Beautiful ladies who own the business are here.
And I asked them if it would be okay,
I would love to feature you guys
on our small business gift guide.
If you go to the DrewBarrymoreshow.com
you will see their beautiful business,
and you too can work with them as well.
Wow! Your mug runeth over.
I mean, we are sending a special congrats
to the team at Fetter Bane too
because they're gonna be first-time exhibitors
at this year's iconic, Philadelphia flower show.
So June 5th though June 13th,
they're having in the Philly area,
this extraordinary flower expo.
So you get your tickets now,
and they've been doing it for 193 years.
For reals?
Yes!
Okay. They know what they're doing then.
I know it's a real, beautiful tradition,
and the activities and exhibits spread across
15 acres of Philly's FDR Park.
So, this is a great story.
And thank you for enlightening me about this.
I really want to go, and visit, and see it.
And next we're actually gonna head down to Philly ourselves,
and meet today's very special Drew-gooder.
Our friend, David Begnaud,
of CBS This Morning filled in to do this report.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Hey, I'm Josh.
I live in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
I'm 24 years old and I am the founder of
New York Bagel Butler.
I'm originally from Long Island, New York,
where I grew up eating bagels all my life.
And when I moved down here, there was just nothing like it.
I had a light bulb moment
while I had a dozen bagels that I brought back
from New York on my counter.
And I was like, "Hey,
why don't I just make this into a business?"
And from that point on,
the first week I had,
I want to say about 11 dozen bagels delivered to people.
And now we're averaging
at about a hundred dozen per week.
The business started in June of 2020,
main pandemic time.
I wanted to give back in some way
and I figured might as well give back food.
Right now, we're up to nearly 5,000 bagels donated.
A lot of this is also like,
it comes out of my pocket,
because I know how many people are out there
who need food, who are struggling.
It's a little bit extra work,
but it's definitely worth it.
(upbeat funky music)
Hey Drew,
it's David Begnaud with CBS News.
I heard about what Drew-gooder Josh is doing.
So I thought let's surprise him, on your behalf of course.
So we drove to Philly with a surprise,
and we thought we'd show up in style.
So, tell me about yourself.
I was working at a law firm,
working from home and had this light bulb moment.
Why don't I just start bringing,
There he is!
Oh my gosh.
Josh!
Hey, David!
How are you?
I'm good. Oh my,
I'm sorry. I'm just a little bit shocked.
We wanted to surprise you.
That's from Drew Barrymore.
Oh my God. Thank you so much.
This is so cool.
Let's see what we got.
Oh, Drew-gooder! That looks so good.
Wow. Oh my God, flowers.
There you go.
Wow.
I actually could not do it without this.
This is so helpful. You don't understand.
There's something infectious about giving back.
And when I saw your story, I was inspired.
Like, I was inspired to do something myself.
Where did you get the inspiration to do what you're doing?
Philadelphia itself
has one of the highest food insecurity rates,
at like 21% right now.
It's like one in five people don't know
where they're getting their next meal problem.from.
And COVID only made that like, a bigger problem.
So when I had the idea to just bring bagels
down as a business,
I made sure that it was like foundationally
built into the business to donate, to give back.
So, what are you doing here?
So right now I'm actually donating some bagels
to one of my drop off spots.
The Block Gives Back,
where they give back to local communities.
One more surprise.
Okay!
Come on.
Let's go!
So, the Drew Show show colors are yellow.
Okay.
And we thought,
why don't we ride up in a yellow car?
500 bagels for you, bro.
Oh my god, that is a lot of bagels!
Liberty Bagels NYC, donating 500 bagels,
so you can pass it on.
Actually, this is insane.
I'm like actually so overwhelmed.
There are a lot of hungry people in Philadelphia
that need their bagels.
Time to drop off some donations.
Want to come with me?
Yeah!
Let's do it.
Here we go!
Special delivery!
(audience clapping)
And now,
joining us this morning,
CBS This Morning's leading, national correspondent,
and dear friend of our show,
David Begnaud!
Hi, David!
Rossy!
Thank you for having me back at your news desk, Drew.
I love you being here.
Can we do it once a week or so?
Ditto, and ditto, and ditto.
Well, any time someone breaks out a bagel, I freak out!
I mean, how did people react to that bagel delivery?
What a wonderful gentleman.
His mother was actually the one who sort of inspired
the give back philosophy when he was young.
And I called him right before I came out here and I said,
how's it going?
And he said, "My tire flattened on the bridge
leaving New York, going into Philadelphia.
And now my deliveries are delayed,
but I called all my people and they said, it's okay."
He's a one man show.
It's a 20 year old guy, 24 year old,
just trying to make a living.
Give Philly some good bagels to eat.
And he's just so likable.
Well, I love a man
who's passionate about bagels.
I think a good bagel is a religious experience.
And not just because they're wholly.
What do you like on yours?
I like cream cheese on mine.
I see that you have peanut butter on yours,
which I'm not angry about.
I'm a peanut butter guy.
David, we heard you are Mr. Peanut butter on bagel,
and I was like, I've never done that.
Is that weird? Is that weird?
No, I love it.
I'll do butter on bagel.
I mean, I'm definitely a schmear girl.
I love a lot of chives too.
Like a scallion cream cheese,
oh, give it to me
But to see someone like that,
to take what they're passionate about,
and use it to help others is so inspiring.
What was like the biggest takeaway you got
after meeting him?
That someone his age could feel the desire
to give that strongly.
And I think the ability to want to give back is timeless,
and it's ageless.
Right? And so, that's what I took away from him.
I just want to know everything his mom did,
so that I can do that as a parent.
That's a good mama!
Because can you imagine how proud his mom is?
And I just have to say, as one mother to another,
what an incredible job you did raising your son,
because he is a good human being.
Someone we all want to be more like,
and thank you, David Begnaud for like,
bringing him to light.
These are the kind of people I need to know about.
Good people are doing good things.
We're gonna be okay.
Uh huh.
(man laughing)
Can we have a bite?
Did you guys think I was not going to eat a bagel?
Two bites, love you both.
Cheers!
I'm having the peanut butter.
Have you ever had a peanut butter bagel?
I haven't.
You gotta try one.
So, can I?
Go ahead!
Yes, of course. Of course.
Okay
I didn't eat breakfast.
Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to Mr. Ed.
(man laughing)
Review?
Okay. Thank you.
Oh my God.
(upbeat instrumental music)